la colère gronde sassari copernic que
nous allons rejoindre tout de suite en
direct
alain gouaméné alain vérité au calme
lancés en fin de soirée par la plupart
des juifs et des responsables religieux
ou la mairie une centaine de
manifestants à quitter la rue copernic
en direct chambre où ils espèrent être
reçus ce soir par le président valéry
giscard d'estaing
en dehors de ces manifestants qui
viennent de quitter leurs locaux par
contre on parle maintenant vers 11h35
est peu à peu bannie dans cette rue où
vous le savez où on viens de vous le
dire s'est passé on tentera absolument
exemplaire les bons pieds à 37 en train
de nettoyer les services d'ordre
continuent à des barricades ne pourront
pas monter jusqu'en haut de la rue
copernic l'échauffement qu'il ya eu en
fin de soirée en terre échauffement bien
bien compris par la plupart des gens qui
étaient sur place
c'était chauffe mans a laissé la place
maintenant un plus grand les on a vu
récemment encore quelques en france et
rejoindre leurs appartements et la
plupart ont soufflé commencent à mettre
de l'ordre en faisant entrer fortune bon
coeur les la plupart et donc en sondant
actuellement dans les hôpitaux et
services d'ordre continuent à
patrouiller tout autour du quartier est
calme semble à l'heure actuelle revenus
est ce qu'on peut dire à 11h35